so yesterday justice stephen breyer
announced that he would be leaving the
supreme court at the end of the current
term but he really didn't announce it it
was just sort of announced for him and
apparently he was kind of ticked about
all of this there are multiple reports
yesterday that he had planned on
announcing this but it sort of leaked
before he was ready for it according to
shannon breme
according to breitbart.com many reports
indicated the briar was surprised and
caught off guard about the announcement
neither brian nor the supreme court has
issued a public announcement about his
supposed retirement the white house and
president biden have refused to comment
on the news which was first reported by
cnbc
biden said there's been no announcement
from justice briar let him make whatever
statement he's going to make i'll be
happy to talk about it later
upon rumors biden may nominate vice
president kamala harris to the white to
the supreme court white house press
secretary jensachi said she would not
comment on any potential nominees here
was jensaki yesterday saying that she
wouldn't answer if kamala harris might
be
continuing her giant ride upward based
on failure i've never seen someone fail
up as much as kamala harris and she's a
failed attorney general she failed
upward into the senate she failed upward
from the senate into the vice presidency
and now there's talk she may fail upward
from the vice presidency into the
supreme court just so they can get rid
of her like she's so bad at vp when the
democrats cannot have her as the nominee
she should joe biden go down they're
like let's just
stick that lady over at the supreme
court she'll be a reliable vote for
anything that we need and sure she sucks
at everything but who cares about that
here is jen saki refusing to answer the
question yesterday
when you were asked about the vice
president possibly being selected as a
supreme court nominee you said you're
not going to speak to any considerations
does that mean she is being considered
again peter i'm not going to speak to
the reports of a supreme court justice
retirement that hasn't been announced so
theoretically would someone who
theoretically i do like that you preface
it i appreciate it just wondering
hypothetically theoretically would
someone who was an attorney general of a
large state and who served with many key
senate votes be an attractive candidate
to the president for an open supreme
court seat i see what you did there
peter but uh the president has every
intention as he said before of running
free of re-election and for running for
re-election with uh vice president
harris on the ticket as his partner
okay so of course that's probably right
they're not going to nominate kamal
harris there are a few complicating
factors first of all kamal harris is the
tie-breaking vote she would have to
presumably resign from her seat as vice
president of the united states in order
to be considered for the supreme court
he'd have to select a new vice president
and at that point that person would be
the tiebreaker because she'd have to not
vote on her own nomination so that's
really kind of ridiculous and insane so
so kamala harris is not going to be the
nominee it is hilarious that the left
was so nervous about the 2022 elections
that they basically just bodily threw
stephen breyer off the supreme court so
you remember that ruth bader ginsburg
the notorious rbg heroine to the masses
the the person that the left worshipped
i mean they made documentaries about her
and they had votive candles of her and
she was the most important justice on
the supreme court despite the fact that
she really wasn't all that important to
justice in the grand scheme of things
for a very few
extraordinarily
important decisions over her tenure at
the supreme court she was just a
reliable vote for the left
justice ruth bader ginsburg made the
crucial error of thinking that hillary
clinton was going to win the 2016
election and so she didn't step down
despite some pressure to do so and then
donald trump won and then ruth bader
ginsburg seat was filled by donald trump
which meant that the court shifted from
basically even to now a 6-3 supreme
court because donald trump got three
picks while he was president of the
united states and
at least two of them were swings right
one was one was ginsburgsy and one was
the the seat
uh for uh for justice kennedy so you'll
remember that ruth bader ginsburg died
in september 2020 while trump was
president she thought hillary was going
to be president and hillary wasn't so
that meant that trump got to replace her
democrats want to avoid that this time
democrats also want to avoid the
situation they had when justice scalia
died because justice scalia died well
there was a democratic president but
there was a republican senate and what
they were afraid of here is that breyer
would pass away or would leave while the
republicans controlled the senate and
republicans could just prevent a
democratic pick from taking the seat so
they basically just announced it for him
he's sitting over there in the corner
he's like yeah i'll probably you know go
and they're like you shut your face
you're leaving now
which is why he's kind of pissed off
according to nbc news president biden
and briar are scheduled to appear
together at the white house on thursday
as the supreme court justice is set to
announce his retirement breyer is one of
the three remaining liberal justices his
decision to retire after more than 27
years on the court allows biden to
appoint a successor who could serve for
decades and in the short term maintain
the current 6-3 split between
conservative and liberal justices now
again this is not a swing seat briar
seat being filled by somebody on the
left would just be a left seat being
filled by somebody on the left at 83
breyer is the court's oldest member
liberal activists have urged him for
months to retire while democrats hold
both the white house and the senate and
he's been pretty
annoyed by the by the pressure that he's
been getting from the outside
uh apparently that pressure has been
mounting over the course of months
there's an article from september 2021
from a site called ballsandstrikes.org
called bullying stephen breyer is good
actually
we need to throw this old man out of
here get him the hell out of here before
ron desantis or donald trump becomes
president and at that point it's gonna
be very very difficult for us to replace
a liberal with another liberal that's
all they care about now who is joe biden
going to replace stephen breyer with
well we know the answer to this one
because joe biden said it back during
the campaign during the campaign joe
biden kept pledging that every
open position was going to violate
federal civil rights law he was just
going to select a black woman for
everything for his vice president for
the supreme court justice for dog
catcher did not matter it was going to
be a black woman no matter what here was
joe biden during the 2020 campaign
saying that he would pick a black woman
to fill the supreme court see because
again by the way this violates federal
civil rights law there's no other area
of american life where you could say i
want a white male for an ex-seat you
couldn't say it it's literally a
violation of the equal protection clause
of the constitution of the united states
you're not saying as one factor among
many i want a woman who has the
experience of a black woman right first
of all that's a ridiculous assertion on
its face because not all black women
have the same experiences but put that
aside even if you use the multifactorial
analysis that the supreme court has been
fond of with regard to affirmative
action programs at universities as we
talked about the other day on the show
even if you threw that aside why didn't
you even say that he just said i want a
black woman okay there is no other area
of american legal jurisprudence where
you could say i want a person of this
specific race and this specific sex to
fill this particular role and that not
be a violation of the equal protection
clause here is joe biden pledging to do
it back in 2020
i committed that if i'm elected
president have an opportunity to appoint
someone to the courts will be i'll
appoint the first black woman to the
courts it's required that they have
representation now it's long overdue
okay so um that is an insane contention
right off the top right i mean and the
fact that we all sort of accept this as
wrote is wild that that presidents of
the united states can now just say
things like that that they can just go
out there and be like i want a person of
this particular race and this particular
sex and it doesn't matter anything else
but this is the way that the left views
the court by the way the left views the
court as two things one a place to put
people of particular races in particular
sexes and two that person has to
reliably vote for the left
hey this has nothing to do with
qualifications now some of the people
who are being considered for the seat
have the usual qualifications for a
supreme court justice namely an ivy
league school and a clerkship maybe a
few years as a judge
that sort of stuff is not
is is sort of de regor for the seat but
democrats don't care about that what
they really care about is we must have
black women
and not only must she be a black woman
she must vote reliably for the left see
here's the thing democrats never miss on
their picks they never ever miss on
their picks ever and the reason
democrats never miss on their picks is
because they just select people who are
overt leftists the right plays this game
it's this really stupid game where in
their hopes of getting somebody through
the senate confirmation process they
pick somebody who's sort of a cipher and
they pick john roberts who's been on the
dc circuit court of appeals for a little
while
has never written a controversial
decision has never been at the eye of
the hurricane and so tends toward the
pragmatist and and the political and and
they never just pick somebody who is
overtly conservative right you never see
the the conservative movement or the
federalist society or the president of
the united states selecting somebody who
is the lawyer for the national right to
life fund they never do this now ruth
bader ginsburg was the actual lawyer for
the national organization for women
hey democrats do this right thurgood
marshall was the lawyer for the naacp
they will just go to an organization
that is allied with them and then they
will say who is your best lawyer and
then they will pick that person they
will elevate them to the supreme court
they don't make this mistake they find
somebody who has been through the wars
on behalf of the left and then they
select that person for the supreme court
or they just openly ask them things like
will you uphold roe versus wade and that
person will be like sure you never hear
the right ask somebody will you overturn
roe versus wade which should be a litmus
test the left gets this right and the
right gets this wrong the left selects
justices based on what they will do
the right should select justices based
on what they will do not on the basis of
political persuasion per se
but based on the reality that the
supreme court has been a political body
and has made political decisions that
are wildly unconstitutional it seems to
me a legal litmus test whether a justice
will vote to overturn roe if you will
not vote to overturn roe you should not
be sitting on the supreme court
certainly not as appointed by a
republican president of the united
states roe versus weight is wildly
unconstitutional it's insane roe vs wade
is a ridiculous decision on its face and
any justice who sort of is unwilling to
say that openly should not be nominated
to the supreme court of the united
states by republicans the republicans
are always going for consensus they're
always looking for we need 60 votes we
need seven votes who cares who cares
first of all democrats don't give you
the authority to do that anyway
democrats will never ever again allow a
republican president who selected
justice and that justice gets through
with 70 votes it's not going to happen
anymore every single republican
appointee is going to be selected with
all republican votes and maybe one or
two democratic votes that's it
so this ridiculous notion by republicans
that when they select somebody for the
supreme court they have to pick somebody
who has wide support it's ridiculous
democrats don't make the same mistake
democrats just assume that republicans
will will admit their people to the
supreme court so long as democrats have
the majority in the senate many of them
will just vote for it and they'll go
along to get along and then they select
people who are overtly left-wing
democrats when joe biden says he wants a
black woman for the supreme court it
does not matter to democrats whether
that black woman is katanji brown
jackson or whether it is cardi b it does
not make any difference one of those
people has the normal resume
qualifications one of those people
absolutely does not but it does not
matter so long as cardi v voted the
white way the right way first of all
they would say that cardi b is a genius
right they would say that if you had
questions about her qualifications this
made you a racist because this is the
game the left loves to play
okay but but in reality they don't care
so long as they get their results
oriented jurisprudence they're done
they're finished now here's the
difference between what the right would
do on this and what the left would do
you could ask a potential right wing
justice like a clarence thomas type you
could ask
should roe versus wade be overturned and
they say yes and then you say well what
should we do with regard to for example
the federal civil rights act in 1964 and
its violation of freedom of association
and you might get a bunch of different
answers because there are a bunch of
different answers on the right to these
questions there is no variation on the
left there's lockstep adherent to basic
rules of interpretation on the left and
those rules of interpretation are what
would a normal elected democrat do we
will do that thing
there is no differentiation on the left
between what the supreme court does and
what a legislature does
no differentiation whatsoever
right where the left sits all they care
about is that a supreme court justice
does what they want that justice to do
it does not matter whether that justice
is being asked to wildly exceed their
own authority
so that is why joe biden can say things
like i want a black lady
and that that's that's why they can say
that because what they really mean is
and we all know this they don't mean i
am looking for a person with the black
female experience or a black female to
fulfill the to rectify discrimination in
the past they mean we want somebody who
fulfills all of our political priors and
happens to please a particular political
constituency
so they can overtly discriminate against
people which is really an amazing shift
by the way it's a it's an amazing tonal
shift in american politics you wouldn't
heard bill clinton doing this in the 90s
you just wouldn't have
and here's the here's the more amazing
thing if joe biden wanted to select a
black woman he doesn't even have to say
it he didn't have to say in 2020 he
could have just selected a black woman
he would have gotten the same credit but
here's the thing if you're a politician
like joe biden you know that in order to
please political constituencies you have
to overtly pledge to be a racist in
advance you have to say in advance i
will select a black woman so that black
people supposedly
this is the way the left thinks about
black voters
that they can be bought with something
like that and if you say that then
you'll win their vote and then you have
to hold to the pledge and this is how
kamal o'hara sends up his vice president
of the united states despite being just
a gas bag of terribleness
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment